welcome to this video lunatic ex lunatic
ex I have played him right but I keep
forgetting Peter mashaallah cure
Grandmaster from czech republic so um
away I wouldn't early d3 okay I'm very
early d3 ok let's play a very simple
reply with should be some think I I saw
something that Bishop c5 might be an
interesting way to play here but ok I
don't mind you to go for this it's very
much like the chil'ren which I have some
experience and obviously answer do this
get for the prepare for the fianchetto
and to ultimately maybe get in d5 and be
nice to manage ok yeah this is probably
trying to do something about the night
on a five and so maybe I should just
retreat it yeah like before or something
at the right moment I am okay so this is
a slightly unfortunate moment for me for
this move because I'd like to play
Bishop be six but he can go nite g5
that's not good and I'm not sure I want
to Bishop on b7 here in this position
I'm clear maybe b7 that's not that bad
because I have good chances to play play
d 5 so I'm going for that sometimes the
bishop is not so good on this end when
the pawn is on d3 still because it
mostly looks at the year for porn which
is securely protected but if I get in d5
this is not relevant really let's see
yeah he's some trying to prevent it
okay can I what can I do here Knight a5
and d5 yeah pushing pushing this through
with force all right now it looks at the
end that will be a trick with Sephora on
my night okay what about Oh bishop yeah
or age 6 just just age 6 preventing 95
it has night h4 that can be an issue
with night xj6 but I don't think it is
that some dangerous okay oh wow this
should be fire this is this a sir I move
that I absolutely didn't think of why
would you give up your bishop pair just
like that ok I won't food understand it
even if I think about it much longer um
ok and 97 y and black is just ok
definitely ok I'm going with before or
just taking this thing hmm I'm not sure
maybe take here first if it takes with
the sea pawn I'm not sure I'm going to
play before I don't want to give up the
c-4 square how do i play here at best
and take take
hmm
Yama this position is is fine for me but
I'm not sure how to play it cb4 may be
here on how exactly is this plate I can
even play f5 or queen hm I'm not sure if
i play Queen a eight and he's trading in
place before what I'm not sure about
this position how good that really is no
but I have Co Africa rugae three so this
is Sir okay b3 so he just wants to
prevent see form I see so um if I go f5
let's do that if we can step inside but
ok how many who is simply place instant
moves the whole time and mostly moves
that I don't understand so this means
i'm getting outplayed or i would simply
don't understand anything ok so now
maybe h5 bishop age 60 yeah okay let's
let's trade this down check ya before ya
that's interesting you this is what I
wasn't always a bit worried about but
let's see the most other the most
important thing is the time I'm down on
the clock he played all this very very
quickly
time warning okay is going down and Joe
I'm not sure
it still should be ok for me I believe
40 seconds I'm this is the the real
problem ok I have to move like age 4 i'm
i'm never losing but he can make a
thousand moves ahead but this is a ser
this is the issue
yeah h was just too dry there is nothing
that you can do with them I'm in 37
seconds so I wonder if I come on I'm do
this often he can win this on time just
by shuffling but it's it's a totally
drawn position check
check-check
check now 17 seconds check check
check check right now no it's a bit
problematic yeah but ok it was it was
simply not doable with with this time
control black forfeits on time it's just
a draw with a modern day time control
nothing to do here i just spent too much
time in the night this is side this is
sometimes happening and people play
pretty much nothing they trade down
everything without any special idea but
at two minutes on the clock is something
um here wyd might never had anything
like it sir it's only a question I mean
around here it's clear that black is
better with the two bishops it's just a
matter of I wanted to play somewhat
quickly to catch up but it's um yeah it
was it simply useless you cannot make
that many jokes and 22 minutes is too
much and she can shuffle around forever
of course it did some some things yeah
I'm trying to to make any make headway
but yeah it is also maybe I should have
actually really played them played a bit
more yeah forward because I can do that
every for example I can do g4 if I want
and try to to play form for an edge even
here I am probably not leading to too
much at the end but maybe it's better
simply to get to get a more active
position but ok difficult with with a
limited time I mean this is just the
draw of it he can shuffle shuffle this
forever and ever and ever but ok he did
something it's not like here he didn't
do it I can't do much so yeah I'm not
really sure about the comp evaluation
computer gives me a clear edge here like
an almost one pawn with King age five
yard maybe I can really enter now here
enter
position possible I'm not sure it's
pretty much useless to analyze because I
will lose it on time in any case um yeah
maybe what I'm wondering about is around
here if here there's some some clear
improvement maybe before I am before
maybe I should have done that I was
unsure about it because of this is
typical weakening of the whoops about
this weakening of the c-4 square but
maybe this is not relevant yeah yeah
stockfish gives me zero point seven year
I mean and it's clear white was giving
up the bishop a totally uselessly with
Bishop g5 was just a bad move yeah yeah
I don't know I don't know um where did I
I mean I'm not touristy bed with my time
and where did I spent that much time I'd
like to I'd like to recollect that he it
was still ok should be seven spent a ton
there but he it was still ok it was not
so still ok and what exactly took me so
long 20 seconds for that and that yeah
it adds up yeah this kind of 10 seconds
all the time he is playing instantly
yeah okay it's not like I spent like two
minutes on one move but I'm constantly
spending like 10 yeah this is also
really the the problem of the games with
Commons I'd like to say a little bit
about my rationale about on each move
and somehow I spent those seven seconds
eight seconds ten seconds and they add
up I mean this is this is really the the
problem okay well thanks for watching